dave it's been a while welcome
back to computer file hello
thanks for joining us i thought it'd be worth
telling the story of um a little mess around
project that you and i did we were discussing
a logo design or a design for something and we
talked about the idea of a wave file or an audio
file because audio is why i come to you and um
to cut a very long story short and so so we can
get into the actual code of it and everything
we talked about the idea of turning audio from
a v from a visual or a wave representation
back into audio so this is kind of like the
world's worst sampling project right yes or
how not to sample i think i said one of your one
of your most popular videos is uh how not to store
passwords and i i remember saying texting you
and saying we should call this how not to sample
so let me just talk through the workflow if that's
not too grandiose a term for this so i recorded
me saying this computer file so that's what
it looked like on the audio recorder i used
you sent me a screen grab of it and you were
saying maybe in your logo have a wave and then
you wrote me as a bit of a joke something
along the lines oh there'll be extra points
if you can get the audio back out of this
wave call it a challenge or something like
that you said it's a challenge and i said all
right challenge taken so anyone watching this
who's a great programmer don't judge the code
this was a kind of like a 25 minute trying to
quickly rush it out and get you back an audio file
as quick as possible so you sent me a high quality
version of it and i kind of i was it was just a
bit of fun we were having during uh during 2020.
2020 fun so how did you go about it then what so
um if i turn around to the side here a second i'll
i'll uh get onto the screen so basically i'll
load up the picture that you sent me so here's
the picture that you sent me and the first
thing i wanted to do was get rid of the adobe
audition stuff around it so i put it into
photoshop and i kind of got the what the color
of the green of the grid behind and basically
removed all of that until it became this so you
can see we're pretty much left with just a black
background and the wave so in in a previous video
i think it's my first ever computer file video
we talked about how computers sample audio and
basically you're drawing a graph of the uh
the pressure waves in the air then that graph
obviously can be shown on the screen and you're
sending me a picture of that graph which is
obviously losing a huge amount of detail and then
i'm trying to reconstruct an audio file that we
can listen to back from that so i was looking
at it and thinking all i'm really interested
in on the kind of like the vertical lines of the
picture is to look at where the top and the bottom
pixels are the the the bright points and basically
have a min and a max for each vertical line i keep
wanting to say horizontal but it's it's vertical
that was my first way of doing it i'm sure there's
loads of ways of doing it and loads of people are
going to leave comments saying oh you should have
done it like this and this was just a bit of fun
that we we did so i've got here the code i load
in the bitmap the file is called computerfile.png
and then i create a new bitmap this is all in c
sharp by the way i create a list of values which
is the values i'm going to get out of the bitmap
and then we go around in a loop here for the width
of the bitmap so i go from zero to one before the
width and then basically i set what my max and my
min and this looks a bit weird because i've got my
mac set to zero and i've got my minimum set to the
height which seems like the wrong way around but
that will make sense in a minute so this piece
of code here goes up each column of the picture
it's going from the bottom to the top on each one
eventually spit out the minimum and the maximum
value of each one so obviously here the minimum
is going to be down here and the maximum is going
to be right up here whereas here the minimum is
going to be here and the maximum is going to be
here so they're going to be different values
in each column in the picture you can see here
that because a lot of it is just a solid block
of color there's no actual wave data in that at
all there's nothing we can get from that so all
i'm doing is kind of going well i want the bottom
there and the top there i just want to know what
those values are and i'm not really interested in
what the shape would be in the middle of that
because we don't know that that would just be
guesswork and i fill that in later so the way i
do that is with this bit of code here which goes
up each column and basically i set the max to zero
and the minimum to the the maximum height and then
we go through and we basically we're challenging
the maximum and minimum we're saying well is this
new value pick the new value the smallest one of
these two and obviously at the moment our minimum
is set to the maximum it can be the fullest height
so if the value i'm getting is smaller than that
then it will reset the minimum and then as you
iterate through each pixel you're going to extract
the minimum and the maximum values from here now
i'm telling whether a pixel is is the green by its
brightness so i'm going to get the pixel at the
point x and y and if the brightness is over 0.5
which is a scale from 0 to 1 then i'm saying it's
not part of the background it's part of the graph
for each column i'm saying i want the minimum
maximum minimum maximum minimum maximum all the
way across the picture and basically creating a
list of numbers you know which is all an audio
sample it's just a list of numbers then i made
this kind of a filter here which actually just
passes a moving average over the whole thing which
just smooths it out a bit and basically stop the
ringing from the sampling errors i then purely so
i can plot the graph i'm going to show you next
output each of the values to a text file here's
the text file so you get all of those values here
and then of course we can move over to libra
office and actually plot them on a graph which
is there so you that was a way of me checking it
was all working and doing what i wanted it to do
of course if i played this if i converted this
straight to a wav file it would go clever and
it would be gone whereas you're saying
computer file or computer file but it's
a bit fun that would be far too quick because in
each one of those columns there's probably a lot
more columns because the picture you gave me was
very very squashed in so i needed to stretch it
and of course depending on the picture that
you give me and how zoomed in or out it was
that stretch amount will change so i had
to experiment with that until i got it to
something that i thought sounded like your real
voice so here i open a new file to write out this
wav file i've got a load of wave header stuff
going on there the bytes that you write for
the header of away file to say that it's 8 bit
or 16 bit or what the frequency is and sample
frequency and everything so and then i've got this
stretch value that i've set myself to 9 which will
elongate or squash up the wave as i want and then
down here for each of the value as i'm writing
it out i go round in a loop around the amount of
stretches i want and i basically add in new data
so if i'm going from this point to this point but
i want nine places in between so basically what
you're having is you've got a minimum maximum
value and in between you're getting a little
bit of one and a lot of the other and then as
you're moving through that increment the the
the proportion between the waiting is going
between the two and in this case i'm doing it in a
way that's very very crude you know you might want
to do it in a more kind of curved way with signs
but again this was just a quick programming
challenge from you over over whatsapp when we
were having a having a conversation so for each
of those values i write out value three which
is the intermediate point and i write that out as
the file and then finally i set the last value to
whatever the current value is and it goes back
around the loop so that it's got the previous
value up here i actually set the last value to
zero so i initialize the variable to zero so
it starts at zero and then it closes the file and
it it was just that simple and i thought i wonder
whether this could work obviously i didn't write
it all in one go like that i wrote out and plotted
the graph and i did it first and heard that it
was squashed up and realized i needed to scratch
and stretch it and add it all in i mean there
was a it's an iterative process i wasn't just
you know write it all out and once and hit go and
it all just worked magically but and much as these
things seem like that sometimes it definitely
wasn't but um yeah and i was i was really sort of
blown away by how how well it worked to be honest
i didn't expect it to work as well as it did
i've got audacity here i can drag over the
newly generated wave file and we can hit play
when i first heard this it just reminded me of the
sort of sampling that we got in 8-bit video games
back in the day so i remember playing a game on
the commodore 64 back in the 1980s which had some
speech synthesis on it and it sounded like that um
some of that was was two bit and four bit i mean
they were really really simple i don't know what
my acorn electron was running back in the days but
yeah i mean it's it's effectively your your you're
in audio terms as as someone who's more of a sort
of an audio engineer in this kind of thing um if
i wanted to get that sound let's say i was doing
a recording and someone said i want that sound
on my voice i wouldn't code something i'd grab
a bit crusher or something that's going to distort
it where it's going to square things off and it's
going to effectively so obviously if you've got a
nice smooth wave you want to have as many levels
as possible within that wave so that you've
got a nice kind of a gradation of different
different volumes effectively that's what you're
measuring of different voltages um and the the
more bits you have to to represent that you know
exponentially gets bigger and bigger and the more
the more detail you can have so eight bits is is
can is so much worse than 16 bits it's ridiculous
and four bits again is so much worse than eight
bits so and we're extracting something here that
realistically i mean i've converted it to 8-bit
but whether i was even close to getting that kind
of quality in the first place i mean i i wouldn't
i haven't even bothered even thought to try and
work out what the source file bit rate could
possibly be the list of numbers straight off
the picture file is presumably a tiny amount
of data it's a 35k file with the numbers and
that's of course written in ascii that's not in
in in binary which would be yeah a hell of a lot
smaller that was just written in a text file from
it to me to whacking to make a spreadsheet but um
i mean i think with all of these things with any
format if you're converting data from one place to
another there will be a way that it seems to fit
sort of in its smallest sense and more naturally
but there will be um you should be able to
represent data in any way i mean i've seen
videos on computer file we've talked
about you know storing data in photos
you know we know with with modems
and other such things you know that
data all the time is being transmitted via audio
and via light with optical signals so whether it's
the most natural format for for that or not is a
different thing but bottom line is they all come
down to a list of numbers at the end of the day
everything becomes a list of numbers you know
this whole exercise though then brought up a
really interesting question uh for me which
which was so let's say i bought a stock photo
on a stock photo website of a producer standing
in front of a mixing desk and on the screen
behind him he had a picture of a wave file and
i've bought the rights to use that picture and
any derivative works from it so if i then reverse
engineer the audio from that picture can i use the
audio because it came from the picture which i've
had the rights to get derived works from which
could be a real problem for let's say sound on
sound magazine interviewing a famous producer and
he's got a multi-track of one of his clients up
on the screen in the background i mean if you had
a really high resolution picture of that you know
you might be able to get out some artist single
before it's been released to the you know to the
market there's some really interesting questions
that come out of this that i think you know in
some ways are more interesting than the quite
simple code i suspect that the only one who's
ever going to benefit from that is a lawyer's
uh bank balance to be honest well if there's a
lawyer out there that watches this channel then
uh then leave us a comment and tell us whether
whether that would uh cause any problems or not
we're not going to pay you though we're not paying
you for legal advice if anything this might just
expose the accuracy of adobe's wave to graphics
capabilities in the first place that overview
i'm using the word overview because that's
what it would be called in in kind of logic or
cubase or anything like that but that overview
that they're writing if you've got a really
really smooth curve and then you squash it up
and you physically haven't got enough pixels on
your screen to represent that um that curve then
you're by doing the zooming of the wave you're
basically throwing away information yourself
and reducing the quality of it and then when
i restretch it i'm having to fill that in so
we're going to lose high frequency data there
also by squashing it that way we're going to lose
um bit depth on it so there's there's
so much that's that's lost from that but
the the fascinating thing for me was the
fact that what we recovered was still
perfectly audible actually they've done a pretty
good job of it yeah yeah i mean it's it has to be
good enough to use and i think like anything when
you do when you're designing a piece of software
you want to write something that's going to
give you enough of the wave that it's going to
be good enough to the user but not so much of
the wave that it's going to eat up processing
power when you're trying to redraw and you
want to quickly zoom in and out of stuff so
obviously what what you're seeing there
without what you're discussing there is the
natural trade-off between those two things so
clearly what they're giving you is good enough
for you to do your work and good enough for us to
actually recreate what you said from it you know
which which is good how's that old camera that
i uh sold you getting on it's wonderful and
it's so lovely that your older canon c100 is
going to make its way back onto computer file
but i am still getting adjusted with looking
at the camera and i've got you down here on
whatsapp are used to people not looking at
the camera anyway yeah that's fair enough
[MANUAL PUBLISH]